it's called them The Odd Couple general
dempsey and Ori Brafman new book it's
called radical inclusion what the post
9/11 world should have taught us about
leadership takes a critical look at
leadership in today's changing world and
they call on leaders to emphasize where
we converge not where we're not where we
diverge to emphasize inclusion general
Dempsey and Ori Brafman it's great to
have you guys at the table thank you you
two are quite the duo we'll get the
history of your relationship yes but I
like one of your first lessons about
leadership came when you were just 22
years old because you've commanded
forces from 45 people to over to 2
million by the time you were done but
here you are 22 years old you get your
first real test of leadership managing
these group of 45 what happened because
there are very different people well you
know you graduated from West Point where
they do a terrific job of getting you
ready and then you go into the Regular
Army and the army I entered in 1774
post-vietnam had huge racial issues and
drug issues and and we were we were
finding ways to pull to pull itself
apart rather than to bring it together
and in that environment is when I first
started thinking about a leaders most
important responsibility which is to
develop in the team a sense of belonging
and that's why we wrote the book because
we think it's even harder to lead today
or you write that a failure to deeply
embrace inclusion would be the defining
leadership failure of the 21st century
what is radical inclusion so inclusion
is more important today than ever has
before
inclusion isn't just a nice-to-have it's
a strategic imperative and the way that
we tackle that is it's about winning or
losing and if you want to win you need
to be inclusive you need to create a
sense of belonging with everyone within
your organization and even more broadly
on the global scale you say not
admission it's also about participation
and that's what people don't get
absolutely yeah Jenny and the reason we
say it's harder today is that the amount
of information that kind of washes over
leaders and their followers some of
which is hard to discern you know you've
heard the phrase you know fake news and
false facts it's it can be
it can be difficult to understand how to
navigate that space as an individual and
then a leader has to help and so we
think developing trust is important you
can really only develop chest if you
include people in every aspect of the
organization we're having a real time
national vision of leadership in the
president so evaluate him in the terms
of your book
I will not evaluate our president in
terms of the book it's you know I'm a
retired military out because military
officers both active and retired are
charged as part of our professional
ethos not to be political I will say
that the book no leader is absent all of
those attributes there's six principles
three instincts and the imperative of
inclusion I think others will judge
whether this particular president or any
president follows those principles and
engineers general let me ask you this
North Korea just this week signaled
openness right to talks about
denuclearization what's your reaction to
those developments my reaction to
developments in the security challenges
we face whether it's North Korea China
Russia Iran you know this radical
stretch from Afghanistan and Nigeria is
that's why we need inclusion you can't
do five things at once by yourself
North Korea is exist in a in a sphere of
influence in part of which is ours
Japan's South Korea's Australia's we
have allies and partners all through the
region specifically about North Korea
look these are the same fellows not the
same ones but this the same country that
negotiated the shape of the table at
penguin Jean in the 50s for three months
we're getting ready to have negotiations
where they will negotiate something
illegal which is a nuclear capability
and we'll be negotiating something legal
which is our presence on the peninsula
the question we have to all ask
ourselves is what will we be asked to
potentially give up or is it worth it is
it in our national interest to do so and
we have to figure out whether we have
the stamina to stick with this because
this is going to be a long process and
we don't want our own readiness to
degrade in the interim but Marty I think
that you would agree
in a country were not our most inclusive
that we've been in history and I think
that needs to change and it's not
inclusive the government's not inclusive
I think so I live in California you can
guess my politics at the same time some
of my close friends started the Tea
Party and on both sides feeling people
are feeling so marginalized and so
unheard and one of the biggest
principles we have in the book is this
concept of listen amplify and include if
you can do that' but that sounds
inefficient to people who want to get
things done it sounds like long meetings
and lots of people talking and nothing
gets done at the end and we're lots of
people learning and one of our
principles is a bias for action in this
environment it's a balance I by the way
these kids who were becoming active in
Florida and they're really demanding
that they be heard that they amplify
good ideas and they're included we think
that's true it's very interesting the
two of you got together you're vegan you
are not I mean friends are worried how
are these two gonna make it work but you
do it's inclusive got yeah because
because you are the example of inclusive
there's someone so many good lessons in
this book thank you for beginning that
discussion we all need it General Martin
Dempsey and Ori Brafman thank you